welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and she-hulk episode 1 sets a high
bar to clear as it introduces to the mcu
in many ways the most challenging vfx
character to pull off especially amidst
a time when marvel studios approach to
vfx artistry is being critiqued but now
that the first episode is here i would
say it mostly sticks the landing thanks
largely to tatiana maslany's charisma or
her chemistry with mark ruffalo as her
cousin bruce banner and when you break
down the visuals of this episode closely
some really clever camera work by the
director kakuro and a team of talented
vfx artists working in tandem to pull
off this illusion so let's go back
through this episode to discuss these
visual maneuvers how they manipulate the
psychology of the viewer and how well
each of them work he's not all of them
do but that's okay we're still grateful
to have shows with green characters to
talk about she-hulk episode 1 starts
with jen walters practicing a closing
argument then flashes back to her
getting her powers actually head writer
jessica gao revealed to variety that
most of this pilot flashback was going
to be in episode 8 but they decided late
in the process to move up jen's origin
story earlier in the season gao said
that led them to have to cut around and
remove many shots of jen hulking out in
episode 1 because there was now no way
for the vfx artist to finish those shots
in time while this change leads to some
oddly edited action with she-hulk in
this episode it's pretty cool to find
all the clever ways that they worked
around it like notice the prominence of
the color green in the set design for
the first five minutes the walls of
jen's office are a pale green the lush
wooded area they drive through and the
color of her car so that when she takes
in bruce's blood we initially see her
vague reflection in the dented green car
door forming a kind of green colored
funhouse mirror to mask her actual
physical transformation but the first
close-up we get of jen at she-hulk comes
when she hulks out on those skeevy guys
outside the bar this is an incredibly
tightly edited seven seconds check it
out what are you too good to talk to us
yeah notice how we hardly have any time
to take in jen's new superpower form
which is just unusual for this genre
whenever marvel reveals their new heroes
for the first time they love to slow
things down and just take their time
like the mighty thor jane foster and
love and thunder moon night in the
bathroom in episode one sam wilson as
the new captain america in the season
finale of the falcon winter soldier even
kamala khan got kind of a slow motion
leap with her embigent hand in her first
episode but here it's like don't look to
look it's barely two seconds before jen
gets tackled and by the way she gets
tackled by hulk even that happens so
fast it's hard to tell that it is hulk
tackling her but that said the brief
frames we do see of jen the vfx artist
did a really good job with her face her
brow is furrowed and raged little
wrinkles over her nose her head is
sweaty there has been a ton of talk
about she-hulk's appearance her face her
height the musculature of her form the
director kakuro told screen rant that
unlike hulk a character who can look
like a monster she-hulk has to fit into
the human world she goes on dates she
goes to work to pull off creating this
character in this physical space they
used to stand in malia araya who is six
foot seven and when it came to she-hulk
silhouette instead of looking at
bodybuilders they based her on slimmer
yet still super strong olympian athletes
and ballet dancer misty copeland but
there's an added challenge with the
creation of she-hulk space actors like
mark ruffalo and josh brolin have heavy
jawlines and just very specific facial
features that allow them to be mapped
onto a non-human skull and still retain
the essence of their facial performance
but with she-hulk jennifer walters can't
look like a cro-magnon she must retain
tatiana maslany's attractive physical
features and this challenge is
compounded by viewers like us being so
accustomed to seeing female characters
on screen wearing foundation and makeup
smoother surfaces which is a huge
problem when you consider that vfx
artists tend to rely on those kind of
imperfections blemishes bumps wrinkles
and stubble to heighten the photorealism
it's really hard to make just a smooth
surface look photorealistic but again in
this episode they work around it in some
really interesting ways in bruce's
basement lab they just nail the eye line
with tatiana maslany looking up so high
at hulk so that she just looks like his
kid's sister until this one moment when
jyn begins to hyperventilate and bruce
lowers to her level making us think that
jen is about to hulk out in size but
really this is just the setup to the cut
to joke of her just being hungry and
during this scene they have a really
good mix of practical props and vfx with
hulk's binder his massive fingers
flipping through its pages making this
binder a kind of visual metaphor for the
burden of being a hulk for bruce this
thick binder is really just a small flip
book as for him his self-actualization
is complete but from jen's perspective
it is a massive stack of paperwork even
for a lawyer one of the biggest finders
she's ever seen representing how this
coming transition is a major shift for
her now later when bruce realizes jen
does not have an alter ego he tears out
that whole first section of the binder
that you'll notice is labeled alter ego
showing how jen is already making this
burdensome token smaller and more
digestible for her one of the fun things
about the fancy shows are the swords
everybody's got a cool sword and it's
their sword and it's sharper than
everything else and it cuts stuff real
good even the iron throne is just a big
old pile of swords swords are cool for
me swords don't really work well with my
daily routine i don't have that many
foes to slay and i don't want to worry
about beheading myself when i shave
just a lot easier to use a razor from
harry's you're not already harry's guy
you ought to be and the easiest way to
get started is the starter kit it's all
comes in one of these packages here's a
razor so the harry's starter set comes
with a five blade german engineered
razor cartridge a beautifully textured
handle some shave gel with aloe and a
travel cover for those times you just
gotta shave on the go and you don't want
your razor to accidentally uh go to war
against your toothbrush in your travel
bag for me the difference is in the
details the handle's just got a good
weight to it and it just feels like it
was built to fit my hand forged for me
also these blades are sharp and there
are five of them so you're just not
gonna find any stray bits of stubble
after you leave the house and thanks to
the aloe in this shave gel your face
will feel smooth and soft when you are
done and when it's time for a new blade
you can order new blades from harrys.com
for as little as two dollars so you can
stay groomed without breaking the bank
harry starter set is normally thirteen
dollars but if you click the link in the
description or go to harrys.com new
rockstars you can get it for only three
dollars so what are you waiting for put
down your sword and pick up a razor from
harry's instead now when bruce has put
jen in that torture chamber notice how
we see her reflection smaller framed
within hulk's larger form through the
glass why do they do this well it's
because the editing of the sequence
again cuts around jen's actual
transformation we never really see it we
just see her green hands suddenly
flattening those saws and then we see
her from behind as she smashes through
the door but since we had that critical
before shot we now have this nice
contrast with her matching hulk in
height now so that her brain just kind
of fills in the difference now this
moment in the lab is really the first
extended looks we get of jen's hulked
out form and close up and notice how
these shots are at their best when they
simply recreate subtle physical choices
that tatiana maslany makes for example
yeah it kind of seems like i'm done here
that's so fast yeah notice her bored
grimace and the awkward fist tap the
more specific of physical choices and
gestures that the actor makes the more
specific of a reference that the
animators have and the more lifelike the
final product comes off there's an even
subtler moment here
fine teach me how to
hulk
please
yeah but slanty does this subtle flutter
of her eyelid like someone having an
angry tick it's just a perfect way of
showing how this character is using her
simmering frustration to fuel her
ability to stay big and green right now
now the next morning are just a few
really good examples of the effects
interacting with the physical
environment to make it all feel seamless
like notice how when jen is hungover
bruce pats her head his vfx hand moves
her physical hair and she says allender
oh
which is a fun joke because she's saying
ow both because she's hungover and as
gentle as bruce was with buzzball he
still hurt her also i love this when jen
tries to leave and goes to the garage
her shorter height allows her to pass
under the blinds but in this same shot
hulk bruce has to lift them up and in
doing so he knocks sublime to skew you
probably noticed how jen also has to
move the seat up way closer to the
steering wheel and sit on her bag to
give herself a boost since of course
this jeep would be customized for hulk's
size i also like how it is completely
covered in mud because as we saw when
bruce got a ride in a new asgard and
endgame he weighs down vehicles and
likely causes this jeep to kick up more
mud than it normally would and as jen
tries to run him over there's another
good example of maslany in a reflection
over bruce's face notice how it's her
eyes in the rear view mirror directly
over hulk's face little detail here as
they fight jen's thunderclaps look like
a sonic cannon like the kind that was
designed by stark tech in the 2008 hulk
film one thing known to slow down or
subdue the hole now there is a moment
after they hug it out that's a little
awkward notice how jen leaves her arms
outstretched just a little too long
suggesting that they might have directed
tatiana maslany to pantomime hugging
giant shoulders but of course the actor
would have had a reference for how long
to leave her arms up i'm not sure what
to do with my hands like it's not that
big of a deal and really i think we can
chalk it up to this just being an
attorney and a competitive cousin who
would be a bad hugger now the final duel
with titania in the courtroom i think
might suffer the most from this episode
not having enough shots of she-hulk to
work with because really it feels like
an edited montage of a fight than an
actual movie fight we get these chaotic
back to back shots of jen and titania
throwing desks without those characters
really being anywhere near desks in the
shots before a desk falls on titania but
we never see her crawl out from under
that desk just a shot of her randomly
leaping into a jump kick a kick that
must miss gen completely because jen
does not even have to step to the side
or turn even to punch titania across the
room so yeah but hey considering they
had to completely reconstruct this pilot
episode i have to hand it to the full
creative team for coming up with such an
enjoyable introduction to the newest
adventure of the mcu and finally someone
who can match the hulk in strength
tatiana mislani is just a natural
superhero and i cannot wait to see her
join the others to take on kang and all
the other threats of the mcu and of
course to watch the next eight episodes
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at avos follow new rockstars for
more of my visual analysis that probably
looks into the details too closely but
you love it thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you